[Musique]
oh
le prénom à nous communiquer non j'ai
réfléchi j'aimerais que notre bébé une
vie normale notre au fonds sera
l'héritier de ce royaume je suis allé à
l'école publique et je prenais le métro
tout seul à 10 ans on trouvera une
nouvelle définition de normes à
l'ensemble mais pas de métro non plus
heureusement pour toi la halle de vie
n'a pas de métro ce soir vous majesté
nous signerons la trêve entre l'al dovi
épingle ia je serai la première reine
elle signe le royaume de penguin est
très attaché aux traditions nous rennes
pouvons mettre la tradition au goût du
jour vous voulez moderniser une
tradition vieille de 600 ans
l'histoire n'est pas faite par ceux qui
suivent les règles je peux aussi vous
offrir nos services
j'ai vu le parchemin c'est un peu
vieillot non c'est une oeuvre d'art
inestimable et j'ai eu le grand honneur
de présider la trêve sacrée entre nos
royaumes pouvez vous procédez s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
au moins maintenant on peut le remplacer
par quelque chose de plus continent qui
dans le parler avait les moyens
l'opportunité est mobile si un jour la
trêve venait à être rompu un sens
s'abattra sur le premier mais si le
traité n'est pas signé avant minuit la
veille de noël
la malédiction s'accomplira
le traité a disparu et si on ne trouve
pas notre bébé sera moi tu vas devoir
m'expliquer tout ça c'est une longue
histoire gestion histoire je prends le
premier avion tu peux me rapporter des
beghal ne juge pas mes envies bizarres
[Musique]
tout ira bien
je crois que je ne suis pas prête pour
être reine est maire
l'avion est en stand by nous décollons
dès que possible
je sais que tu ne crois pas à cette
malédiction mais là j'ai besoin de temps
et on retournera tout château s'il le
faut mais personne ne fait noël comme
les halles devient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il y a j'arrive même pas
attrapé mes chaussons permettez moi
c'est parfait
[Musique]